parents have gotten into this place
where they want to be their kids friends
or they don't want to deal with the
confrontation that comes along with hard
parenting and that's hard I succumbed to
it at times but my mom didn't like my
mom never feared confrontation even
though she was the sweetest with me she
just didn't coddle yet she made me think
you know think that I was the best in
the world because I thought I wasn't the
best in the world at everything you want
to start off with something that's very
near and dear to my heart this show is
called perfectly mentored you believe
you are perfectly parented yes as
someone who has two little kids growing
up uh two and a four-year-old and I want
to talk about that because you talk a
lot about building self-esteem yes and
one of the questions I get from there
and when I when I listen to you talk is
where's the line between self-esteem and
then I'm doing too much coddling correct
delusion I think um
what is what was not even a thing
coddling when I was a kid in the 80s was
my mom just held me accountable I mean
like you know this is incredibly
Politically Incorrect by today's
parenting standards but like if I like I
saw kids do something in the last week
at the playground grabbing a cab the
other day like that my mom would
absolutely knock me out for like I saw a
kid say to his mom shut up and I
shivered
shivered this happened this weekend
shivered because I know for a fact if I
said that to my mom she would have
smacked me as hard as she possibly could
in my face now that isn't what we do
nowadays as parents a
I don't want to make another violence
where I get completely canceled but a we
need to learn as modern parents what
there was many bad things that happened
with spanking your kid whipping your kid
but you know the reason I wasn't over
coddled was I wasn't overcodeled meaning
telling your kid that they're a great
person that they're wonderful uh telling
them that they're good at baseball when
they are good at baseball
telling them they're bad at baseball
when they're bad at baseball is
something that isn't been done as much I
see it because my son's good at baseball
and I watch parents that have kids that
are bad at baseball telling me they're
that they're good and I'm like they're
not and I also tell my son when my son
tells me he's gonna be in the NBA I'm
like you better learn how to shoot 40
from the field from half court because
you're going to be under six feet tall
and if you're gonna be in the NBA you're
gonna have to do some crazy 3.0 version
of Steph Curry where you're like
literally hitting half court shots
because Defenders that are six seven
point guards by then are gonna be able
to give you no room to shoot so you
better figure this out that's talking
real to a kid but a lot of parents took
the take in the last 30 years that was
me crushing his dream that's delusion
and then and then finally it's no
accountability parents have gotten into
this place where they want to be their
kids friends or they don't want to deal
with the confrontation that comes along
with hard parenting and that's hard I
succumbed to it at times but my mom
didn't like my mom never feared
confrontation even though she was the
sweetest with me she just didn't coddle
yet she made me think you know think
that I was the best in the world because
I thought I wasn't the best in the world
at everything
yeah I was gonna say I feel like my
mother too right there's this amazing
line that they walked of making you feel
like you could do everything but kind of
being realistic with with what that
everything kind of was and I think I
feel like now we lost that I think we
lost it
my talk by this like all I know is how
to do my part my small part obviously I
have a big platform by humans standard
but my platform is not going to change
all 8 billion people on earth I would
argue that there's many
countries inside of the continent of
Africa that have never heard of me like
20 people know me so I can only we're
gonna we're gonna boost this up but but
you know I think the reality is is that
um the way we do it is one percent of
time and so and then you scale it
through content because like I I look at
my kids I'm like okay you're great
you're great you're they're two and four
they don't they aren't they could think
they're two and four is a great time to
be delusional yeah because they don't
even know what they're thinking of
fireman and Astronaut cool also the best
but then it gets to a point where we're
telling the kids that they're so great
and then they go out in the real world
that's right and the real world's not
going to tell you you're great no it's
actually going to tell you how awful you
are it's actually not going to tell you
how awful you are I I really I it's
gonna tell you what it is
right yeah the real world's just going
to be based on Merit and so I don't
think it's awful I think a lot of you
know I don't think social media is awful
I don't think the real world's awful I
just think it's no but you're awful
they're going to tell you you're awful
that that and so like if you have a
parent who's like look you can I think
it's remarkable to say you can be
anything you want I think the part that
has also been lost is hard work
like the world is struggling to find its
way with hard work because the world is
doing a good job of being thoughtful
about burnout I love that
I love that I use the word worth I love
that I use the word word ethic now
instead of the word Hustle not because
of anything else but if the world has
taken the word hustle and changed it on
me which is what happened when I used
hustle it just meant you've got to give
effort yeah it didn't mean getting
yourself into depression and don't sleep
and use drugs to cope that's not how I
defined it that is how the world defines
it I am thrilled to adjust my word
but the world is struggling with the
word work ethic
Justice
and so what ends up happening is parents
are struggling to find that balance yes
you can be better at everything in the
world there's not one thing in the world
that I don't think I can be better at
not one skiing teaching
punching eating there's everything I can
be better at I can't be world class at
everything that is something the world's
gonna have to get better at honey you
could be anything you want in the world
with no honey you can maximize your
natural talents in every category if you
put a lot of work ethic into it you just
might not be Beyonce and LeBron and
that's awesome but like for example I
love basketball
it could be way better I could tomorrow
hire a new shooting coach I'm wealthy
now I can hire a shooting coach can come
to my apartment even every day of the
week I can get up at 6 a.m I can
completely change my form because
unfortunately when I was in high school
I played on a nine foot rim with my
friends so I'm five eight five nine on a
good day so I play like a six eight six
nine person because I played on a nine
foot Rim so everything's like I play
like a big man like I've got great
inside like touch but my shot acts like
I'm like a power forward Center and so
it's ugly I could be better
but to what degree I could be a better
at pickup I could be better than my
brother even though he's better than me
now if I really went hard for the next
five years and worked on my game uh but
I'm not gonna be in the NBA
and we've got to find that place with
our I do it with my employees I do with
my employees I do it with my family I
deal with everybody in the world through
content because it it leads to a better
place but then there's such a fine line
between you helping and you being a
Dream Crusher correct but a Dream
Crusher is based on delusion like again
it's a very simple sentence dad I'm
going to be ex cool anything that isn't
physical
I would argue is in play if somebody's I
think it's much easier to be the
president of the United States of
America than it is to be an NBA player I
think it's much easier to be famous on
television than it is to be a to be an
NBA player I think it's much easier to
be the greatest Chef in the world than
it is to be an NBA player I think where
crushing dreams has to come in is a
little bit you know based on realities
of physical stuff
right you know I just think that's real
and a lot of people gravitate towards
physical stuff early on but if somebody
says they're gonna be an astronaut
everybody's in play for an astronaut now
if you're like my mom and everything
makes you nauseous
you know one could argue you have more
hurdles to get over you know to become
an astronaut but I still think you can
get over the hump on nausea I did by the
way on the record in my youth I
struggled with flights and I would get
my tummy would hurt I threw up on
flights in my teenage years now I take
flights every hour of the day so I got
better Heights I'm better like I'll live
high now at my office eye like you know
like so you can get better at things but
I think that Sports is dangerous
you know I actually argue that
entrepreneurship is dangerous
it's something I'm trying to figure out
it's really hard to be a great
entrepreneur if you're not born one like
great like I which is why these are
conversations that need nuances I think
being an entrepreneur that makes 400 000
a year in Revenue
against the business that lets you take
home 93 000 because you run it very
profitably around something you like uh
HR policing
um
Consulting against a specific you know
Internet of Things AR web3
um people management like I would be
great at having a one-man Consulting
business around HR great at it it comes
natural to me I've done it I'm good at
it and I could make a really good
company that does five million a year
that I make three million in profit yeah
you know there's people that are not as
great in HR as me but could make a nice
one-person shop with Freelancers doing
600 000 a year because they have two
three retainers at 100K right
that is very feasible but that's based
on self-awareness and I think it's a
great life
the problem is everyone now thinks you
need to make a billion dollars when you
start a business
so these are nuanced combos hey Daddy
I'm obsessed with revenue
is a vanity metric I'd much rather make
one million and keep eight hundred
thousand than make three million and
keep twenty five thousand and I'd rather
make 3 million and make 25 000 believe
it or not listen to what I'm about to
say this is so nuanced because my whole
life I know three million get the 7
million and if I make three million and
twenty five thousand I know I can make
seven million in three million versus
one what hurts a lot of great
entrepreneurs that I see on paper is the
one million 500 000 profit thing because
they're paying for their lifestyle on it
and I'm like no no you actually can get
the 10 million eat a little more [ __ ]
make a lot less reinvest in 10 on 30
margin becomes 3 million versus 500 000
at one but then there's another you're
also creating operational drag in your
business you just beat me to it one
thing that countered my thesis on that
over the last decade was like oh [ __ ]
I've watched Friends take that advice
and they loved life at 500 000 take home
and they hate life at one million take
home because now they're managing Carl
yep yeah yeah
so self-awareness Nuance against a kid's
dream is the game
dad I want to be an NBA player son
daughter WNBA player you have physical
limitations based on our family history
but
easily you can play D3
if you decide to go Steph Curry route
and start shooting from [ __ ] a
hundred yards away you could do anything
that's going to be the only way
you better get real serious real fast
that's a good combo and shoot for the
NBA but land in being a great like I've
had my son just turned 10. I have like
realistic combos with them like you're
gonna love going hard at this because if
you don't make the NBA you're gonna be
the best pickup player in your friend
Network and from 22 to 40 that's just a
lot of fun and like those kind of combos
with kids which is like you don't kill
the dream but you give it a little bit
of a realization same with
entrepreneurship because I'm at the
Forefront of this now I tell a lot of
people I'm like you can have this really
good business if you're going for like
Mount Rushmore Fame of Entrepreneurship
you better really look inside of like is
that the only thing you've ever done the
way that it was the only thing that I
ever done since I was five and can you
deal with everyone hating on correct
because as well liked as you are you
still get a lot of [ __ ] talking a
hundred percent and that
and I think that eats the one bad
comment and I used to be the same way
one bad comment made me want to delete
the entire post made me want to shut
down made me want to that's hard and you
know for me right now I think in the
last three years I've crossed over to
that next level of like I would argue
like oh crap a lot of people really know
who I am like three years ago I could go
out into the world and go to dinner and
come home and not be stopped it's
inconceivable I could I can't even walk
outside this building for not to happen
and that's cool in some ways but it's
been very challenging in others because
it's all now just amplifies and so it
used to be a hundred people with [ __ ] on
me
but you'd get a million people of love
and that was awesome now all of a sudden
you have five million to love in a lot
of ways there's something that happens
at this level that it's not 500 that
[ __ ] on you it's more like 1500 so the
ratio changes
and 1500 sitting on U-verse 100 feels
more
and that's when you got to really lean
into who you are and like what are you
about and do you really know yourself
are you delusional about your own self
every time I get hate the first place I
default into is not [ __ ] on them not
what I even what I say publicly is true
I feel bad that's a shitty way to live
but one thing I don't talk about I'll
say it here that I actually really think
I do a lot more than I realized is I go
immediately into self-reflection is this
hater right and I like doing that
the reality is it's not really 99 of the
time that's not true not really 90 time
not really 75 percent time and never
like purely exactly because a lot of
people come with I mean I just go into
the mindset of like there's nothing that
anyone could post political religion
anything someone could post that would
make me want to take time out of my day
to actually write a negative comment I
barely write positive comments on
people's posts so my mind goes into an
empathetic motive correct what is going
on in this person's life that this is
where they're spending their time yeah
me too I just if I really feel bad I
really really really feel bad because
for you to be at a level of that level
of hurt that you need to hurt someone
else to feel better you've now crossed
over into a different place so let's
talk about that because there are people
who don't put out content for that one
reason yes another reason is you know
buzzword of authenticity yeah everyone's
talking about be authentic the problem
is when all these people are consuming
you they're consuming you know uh
everyone else on the planet and then
they put out content and the hardest
part is where does their Voice start
where does their voice where are you
listening to you say I'm empathetic to
those like I'm listening right now I
think about it all the time I'm like am
I the seed of things
you know like for me it's easy but so I
actually this is a very important
question
because most people are sponges you
ready for this yeah I consume nobody
and haven't I actually think the reason
I've been very original
is I don't consume anything I consume
everyone
but I don't consume any other
person that does what I do you can send
the listeners I consume the comments
I just don't have time I'm so first of
all you know this because you have a
little bit of insight I'm a very weird
character most people have no concept
that I'm running a 350 million dollar a
year Global agency every day actually
like you and you know you just walked in
here I'm finishing off and meeting with
a Fortune 50 CMO like literally just
closing so let's go right like it's what
I do yep so that in itself isn't insane
then I have real love for my family and
want to live that personal life
and then I'm like me and I'm a maniac
I'm doing [ __ ] garyvee and I'm doing
V friends and I'm doing like garage
selling like and so I don't have time to
consume anything but the consumer
consuming somebody else that's
synthesizing the consumer
has no value for me so your advice says
everyone turn off everyone and just put
out the content about you based on them
listening to everybody so for example
when nobody on Earth knew who the [ __ ] I
was and I was doing wine I read Twitter
20 million hours a day
to read every single person's point of
view online
so think about that for a minute nobody
knows who I am and I'm Twitter I started
a YouTube show and Twitter just comes
out and I'm like Twitter and there was a
site called semis.com which Twitter
bought and that became the technology
that is Twitter search yep so at first
Twitter wasn't Bobo's desktop
and you had no idea what everybody else
was tweeting you just go down different
streams you'd follow people and then
this search engine for tuner came out it
was profound changed my life I used to
talk about semis a lot of 2007 and eight
and I was like wait a minute anything
and I was like wine enter and be like
and Twitter was all Silicon Valley so
almost every comment was going to Wine
Country this weekend all the VCS right
yeah and I would be like and then I was
like wait a minute I could jump into
this like hey
fancy BC of that because now I'm
learning that world uh if you need any
VIP tours and then it led to Consumer
insights I was like what are people
thinking about Merlot Merlot [ __ ]
sideways came out and everybody wanted
Pinot Noir and hated Merlot so now that
dictated my content I do that to this
day
to this day I I know more about what
people think of of She-Hulk
on Disney plus from this weekend then
anybody would understand that's because
I'm a psycho for Consumer awareness and
pulse and insight do you think that's
why because you say post on every
platform and you post four times a day
just put out content do you think that's
why people who are doing that people are
putting out for you know four posts per
per platform but they're not growing
well they're not growing because do you
think it's because they're an echo of
somebody else I'm like no I who the [ __ ]
does Gary vaynerchuk wannabe
I think
so yes but not exactly that I actually
think it's because almost everybody
produces content from a place of selfish
I just think that's what it is I when I
look at the content I'm like this person
could be good
but the only thing they're putting out
is for them to sell their course so
what's the recipe
put out content as if you work on
television or work at a newspaper or
work out radio for the 50s 60s 70s and
80s and media was a public service
domain
I'm a throwback I'm Walter Cronkite way
more than I'm anything else
and what I mean by that was Walter and I
don't the context was Walter Cronkite
was a newsman that was in an era where
they were taught when he was growing up
in the 30s and 40s and 50s that the news
was a public
public entity that it was there to
service the public
from the day I sort of went and it
happened I got very lucky in hindsight
of how I grew up in the game
I wanted to be content to review wine I
thought when I started Wine Library TV
in my head before I did it that I was
going to do QVC I was going to do videos
and I'm going to sell wine
I have no idea why my DNA did this the
second of the I can actually pinpoint it
in episode one as a matter of fact team
I want to actually make this piece of
content I'm gonna pinpoint on an overlay
the second my life changed which is
within the first five minutes I have to
look at the video to get the exact time
I go into episode one I got three
bottles of Verte I remember the wine
because we had a lot of it and it was
profound like there was a part of me
that was selling good stuff thank God
right so like the wine was very good and
underpriced compared to Opus One and
Dominus and Silver Oak so I was like I'm
gonna make a good first episode but it
was there because I wanted to sell it
and within [ __ ] five minutes I'm like
oh [ __ ] I'm not gonna sell on this show
I'm gonna act as if I left my dad's
business
and I'm just reviewing wine because I
have to be valuable to them
and I practiced a thousand episodes of
that reviewing wine which is why the
show went crazy the show confused
everybody if you look at the early
comments like wait a minute doesn't he
sell this wine
because I'm on the show saying all right
here we go
oh my God this one is incredibly
disappointing the mid palette is hollow
how are they charging 65 for this this
is an 18 bottle of wine and people are
like what is going on and my own family
was my best friend Brandon my dad my
cousin Bobby all my employees were like
have you lost your mind we have 25 cases
of this who the [ __ ] gonna buy this
I'm like people that don't watch a show
like I don't know like like and it was
like very real and then obviously when I
went to business content
it was never there like when I got
serious about vaynermedia I stopped
making content
every move I've made is very clear
it's there for my legacy
for being historically correct for
reputation building
right
which of course as a brand trickles down
into business people know you people but
it's not there as a monetizable
individual event unless I throw a right
hook yep and I'm comfortable when we
launch empathy to say hey buy it but
it's so infrequent so the the issue is
right when people listen to you talk and
I don't mean this in a negative way it's
like Gary has millions of followers
right easy for him to say post this
whatever he post is going viral I'm you
know 1 500 follow or or I'm I'm 200
followers
and I'm listening so I want to make this
a little bit tactical if we can if you
could go back or knock back you're right
now with with the topic with the
platform Tick Tock just I got attentions
yeah hi you lost your reputation yeah
you no longer could use your name to
sign anything you could just be garyvee
with your mindset with your mindset
right now how fast do you think you
could build a successful company and how
would you do it
well that last part made this more
interesting
so the fact that it says even the
question gets exciting for me because
she said how fast can you build a
successful company
even that is why I think most people are
not winning
I've never thought of anything besides
how slow can I build something
speed matters now I like I mean I I
think speed is the poison yeah okay
speed matters I also think it's why
nobody's winning
speed is the devil
but so is sitting and analyzing and
never doing no [ __ ] right so there's an
office that's right does it count do you
know why everyone's sitting and
analyzing so much because they're trying
to figure out how to do it fast
speeds the [ __ ] devil
the the it was really funny obviously I
you know back to jumping in that was a
really fun moment right because I'm
saying tick tock tick tock because I
think you're gonna go where do you start
and that's that's why that's why I
didn't stop and I appreciate that I like
how you did it the reason I went so ham
four years ago on Tick Tock was I knew
what the [ __ ] question is from
everyone I was like [ __ ] this could
actually get people going because we've
gone through five years of mature
Facebook and Instagram and it was like
there was no fast Tick Tock was the
first thing that I saw that was fast
completely based on the Merit of the
creative
but the problem is a lot of the people
that got it fast didn't necessarily go
into it trying to get it fast some of it
was on a spoof on a lark
some heard me and talked about [ __ ] they
cared about and because they cared about
it and they were passionate about Star
Trek and they knew a lot about [ __ ]
Spock and Captain Kirk it hit for the
people that also did
so you know I think the interesting part
of your question the answer to your
question is I if I was exactly me would
be okay because I've never wanted fast
because I've always sensed and now I
feel very confident that I'm right at 46
years old that fast is what [ __ ]
everyone up because you go into shortcut
land and that's just real talk it just
is
uh so I couldn't recommend more people
trying to think about things like okay
and this is why I [ __ ] with the
youngsters for the youngsters I'm like
listen
when you're 20
. if I'm telling you 10 years when
you're 20 you were 10 years old 10 years
ago and I remember being 22 and my
cousin Bobby being 30 and I thought my
cousin Bobby was the oldest man on Earth
so I know how hard it is when I tell
them hey think of this as a 10-year game
they're like [ __ ] you Gary that feels
like forever
the problem is it's why so many 20 year
olds lose it's also back to mental
health and all that it's why they're all
so anxious they want fast to show
everyone else they want
they don't want fast for any other
reason but to flex
and that's really [ __ ] them up fast
is the devil the cancer is doing it for
other people thinking you made it
so now you got fast cancer is how most
of these kids are playing it you had so
you used some of that towards towards
your view like you you say it all the
time where people thought you were a
loser because you were the entrepreneur
like growing up you use that as a chip
on your shoulder chip on shoulder is
very different yes I to your point yes
but the problem is when I was growing up
and using it as chip of the shoulder I
wanted the Merit of success to be it I
never thought anyone on Earth would know
who I was
either in the business Community I
literally thought in the liquor business
people would know me and that was my
life
so I didn't grow up with what these kids
want almost every kid subconsciously
wants Fame it's [ __ ] insane
there's a reason why most actors and
actresses especially child ones went to
rehab it's [ __ ] hard back to what
we're talking about right I want to chip
on shoulders to like be successful for
the game
a lot which is why I never bought [ __ ]
to this day it's why I don't buy [ __ ]
because I don't want the proxy I didn't
want the Mercedes or BMW or Rolex or
house in the [ __ ] in Short Hills with
a pool and a house in the Hamptons I
didn't know the Hamptons existed until I
was 30 years old I grew up in Jersey my
whole life I knew nothing about the flex
now back to chip on shoulder to your
point is motivation it's the perception
of success that all these kids want they
want blue check Money fake chain the
girl the guy the photo and Ibiza to make
pretend they're successful
that's the most [ __ ] cancerous of it
all
so what's your so I mean before we even
get to the advice how would you do it so
you have no rep you have you're not you
you lost all your followers you have no
contacts no reputation anymore step just
your mind how do you build it step one
for everybody who's listening who's in
this spot which is almost everyone yep
you have to be step one self-aware of
how you're best at creating content
step one are you a writer are you audio
are you video if your video it will
always have the most upside just the
truth of the way the world works
movie actors are more famous than
authors it's just the way it works but
if not don't force it so is it written
word audio or video step two
scalable format you know when we cross
paths and do a q a show that's scalable
right you know to me I can't produce
content I'm too busy but I can double
bubble I can do something and put
somebody on like I am right now I can
get the content that's how I feed my
machine so step two becomes first you're
like what that's how you get Podcast
number three you know so how do you you
know how do you how do you a communicate
B what's the most scalable thing think
back to what I did when nobody knew who
I was what's the most scalable thing I
can do oh there's a million Wines in the
world I'll never review them all and
every day I can wake up and go
downstairs because I have a liquor store
and grab three bottles of wine and
review them so I did it from day one a
scalable thing I think q a or
even if you somebody said to me the
other day it was really fun combo he's
like I can't do q a because I literally
nobody knows who I am I can't even ask
anybody to ask me a question I'm like
you know anybody because I was like just
bring them on he's like not really I
said back to some eyes I said great news
your content should be taking people's
questions all over the Internet or
comments and make contact look what's
going on on Tick Tock replying to
comments in video form are the most
viral [ __ ] going you can go and do that
from other people's accounts you can
stitch and do what your way to the hall
of fame
it's all there if you're willing to go
there but you gotta so for me it would
be first who am I I would say on video
next I would go to how do I bring value
everyone can bring value I really
believe that every person listening
right now does have strengths or at
least our enthusiasts or opinionists a
lot of time people want to be an expert
before they they make pretend they're an
expert which is why they die on impact
all those fakers out there all those
garyvee fakers that you referenced
earlier because they're not actually
marketing experts
that's why they're losing they know what
the [ __ ] they're talking about but then
you have the people who are good who
have imposter syndrome and they don't
know how to get over that as well
correct that's insecurity right like
that the way to get through insecurity
is through sheer will it's by consuming
the negative consumption of your life
got you to insecurity Mom Dad School
older brother like could be a million
different things the only way to get
into that is the positive reinforcement
the reason I work so well for so many is
I'm that positive Pusher and then they
go do it and they're like [ __ ] I could
do this the whole time
and so I love being that for people and
I want more people to replicate that
behavior and so for me it's it's really
that and so you figure out your who you
are you talk about what you know or what
you like I'm trying to get a lot more
people to think of themselves as
enthusiasts instead of experts you could
be a Jets Enthusiast you don't have to
know as much as I do about the Jets pure
history just talk about liking it and
you're excited about you know you know
whatever your Zach Wilson's this or or
Garrett Wilson that or Robert salad this
it comes back to the posting of the
content again of Gary could talk about
whatever he wants because he has that
attention well I go on and say I enjoyed
the Jets game today that's such a losing
mentality and I'll tell you why
on that theory
it completely takes out of the account
that Logan Paul and Charlie demilio and
Gary vaynerchuk had zero followers when
they posted the first time
because that's the truth because I know
both of those two careers so I'll use
them as much bigger audiences than me
playing in that youth culture
like I don't understand that mentality
at all
oh they're giving up before they even
start yeah I mean there's no logic to it
like like if someone's able to do
something but I think that's that's what
people do right they put their Heroes on
a pedestal because then they don't have
to there's a reason right oh I can't do
it because Gary's unique I can't do it
because Logan's unique they put them up
on a pedestal and they never have to
reach that Fame because look they're
unicorns I can never do it and look
listen I think there are people that are
naturally you know first of all you look
at like the rise of Instagram in the
Instagram era being attractive
was a real skill set it was an ERA for
models both male and female and you saw
a lot of people raising Fame by just
being attractive attractive can be
bought we've seen that in our culture
now but for the most part that's like
not something you can control in the
same way
when you look at Tick Tock being funny
being creative
you know that's a skill set yes that
could be refined more than being
attractive though you can work out and
do things and you know it's just getting
people to understand everything is
controllable on your level if you really
want to go there you know every time I
say being attractive a lot of people DM
me and they're like you're wrong and
show me a million examples oh that clip
got a 500 000 views over a million views
with what we spoke about about being
good looking but it's you say in your
control versus out of your control
I think we've seen a lot and I'm going
to bring this down to marketing question
because you do run an agency right
that's specializes in marketing and
advertising yes
there's with iOS issues yes and platform
changes all these brands are focusing on
everything that's outside their control
versus the things that are inside the
control how do you make your website
convert better how do you how do you how
do you get from a 1.5 conversion rate to
a two and now you make more by the way
the marketing is in their control as
well like the algorithms changing or
retargeting changing is no different
than you're running ads on let me just
give you the historical comp you bought
TV commercials as an upfront to be on
Seinfeld and then Seinfeld decides it's
not going to come back the problem was
you also had all these people grow
during a covet era where it was they
could see their one dollar and five
dollars out really mathematicians yeah
fair right this is very important you're
right I want to make this point for
everybody here there's a very diff big
difference between being a full marketer
and being somebody who's a math Quant of
the moment marketer models have it
harder on Tick Tock than they did on
Insta Instagram because you got to do a
little something
mathematicians who are purely math have
it much harder in iOS 14.5 posts than
they did pre because they would run
unlimited Facebook because it was the
greatest machine of all time they would
get you to the website they would cookie
you and they would retarget you into
Oblivion where the creative was almost
non-existent to adjust
yeah so
we're about to be hit or we're in or
it's coming or maybe it's not a
recession
with all these brands that are looking
at all this right and and that's the
first thing they cut is advertising yes
but it's the biggest mistake because you
need more customers and more sales so
what's your advice to Brands when this
is going to hit when those recessions
coming and the first thing they're going
to look at is well Facebook isn't
doesn't work the same way it did when we
were in a unicorn moment where
impression or impre cost per impression
was at an all-time low and at attention
was an all-time high because people are
home you're not going to have that
moment anymore but they all tripled on
Advertising spend and they grew the ones
who didn't shrunk what's their advice to
Brands heading into this recession now
foreign
the hardest times or the easiest times
the answer is always to do the best
thing you can do with every penny
right so for me the advice is
hey if you're going to cut let's
remember every business is different if
you're a publicly traded company
you're a big boat
you're not like us where you're fast and
your Tailwinds are what they are I'm not
fast anymore I'm slow I have to listen
to this podcast it's awesome and so I
think for a Coca-Cola cutting marketing
makes sense because they're being held
accountable to their stock price every
90 days and they need it otherwise it
could become a problem right for those
people I say cool you can cut your
marketing budget but now's the time to
fire all these [ __ ] agencies that do
nothing and you better get every you
know to me whether you have a dollar if
you have 50 cents I'm actually not
emotional about that I'm just emotional
about it actually doing the thing you
wanted to do for big big companies they
waste 90 cents on the dollar with the
old advertising ecosystem that I'm in
and that's why we're exploding right now
because of this looming recession
because now at the scale we're at
everybody knows who we are and what we
do and they know that they were paying
somebody else 8 million this year in fee
that we could do it better at five but
they didn't have to do anything about it
now they do so that'll be our growth
time
but for the entrepreneurs out there this
is the time to really look at what
you're spending your money on in your
real life
and maybe you don't need to go on four
vacations maybe go to two maybe you need
to trade in your Lexus for a Toyota
maybe you don't have to go out to dinner
every day maybe go out once a week maybe
you don't buy seamless and Uber and
Starbucks every day maybe you do it you
start really cutting so that you don't
have to cut your marketing budget
because now is when growth is going to
happen I like the fact that you said
that because I think people try to save
their way into wealth you could cut
costs as much as possible eventually
that sponge runs out and you can't grow
a business by cutting expenses you can
only grow a business by bringing a new
business you can only save your way into
comfort correct not into wealth
it's just too hard
like it's just too I watched my dad do
it I mean he did great but like defense
is defense there's you know back to
American football like prevent defense
loses football games
and so you know you watch a football
game for I'm just going to be very nerdy
for American football fans right now you
watch a football game your defense does
what it does the whole game they've kept
the team to 10 points they're up 13-10
and the other team gets the ball they've
only given up 10 points in the first 53
minutes of the game 58 minutes of the
game and now you switch up your deep
ends to not make the big mistake which
gives them all the room to Dink and dunk
their way all the way to the field and
score that's why teams hate prevent
defense it's why the best defense in the
last decade don't really go there
and that's how I think about savings
look you have to work with your means
and for me as a human human beings that
are listening right now they need to be
saving their money on not spending it on
dumb [ __ ]
spending on marketing for your business
that works is the smartest thing you do
spending your money personally on five
dollar coffees 17 times a week yeah is
how you spend if you cut that to three
and make your own coffee at home
it's how you [ __ ] have the bucks to
spend like that's why I always push
savings is huge for entrepreneurs but
not like go defense it's don't spend
money on things you don't need when it's
harder
got a couple of minutes with you left so
I want to wrap up with with a couple of
questions so one is I can't do a podcast
with you and not talk nfts really
quickly you had VidCon
amazing amazing event what you do for V
friends everyone who talks about nfts
says what you do for your communities is
huge then a couple weeks later whole
like
implosion of what's going on how do you
see what's happening in that space and
and with crypto during this coming
recession I mean I'm so excited about it
you know one of the things that worked
for me was because everyone's sitting
there saying ah told you this this art
doesn't yeah I don't hear I don't hear
that noise plus I was the one who said
it you know one of the great things for
me is I put out unlimited content that
98 to 99
nfts were going to zero so it's nice to
be right it's atrocious to be right when
you know how many people are hurt on the
other side
um but that was greed and not playing
with like if you lost like I lost an
ungodly amount of money on the things my
current bags hey I haven't sold yet you
only lose when you sell
to every one of those dollars were
dollars that I could afford to lose
the people that are most bent out of
shape rightfully so are the ones who
spent money they couldn't afford to lose
and didn't heed the call that 99 we're
going to zero
the problem is they have to be
accountable the content was out there
the reality was out there what do I
think is happening the same thing that
happened when the Internet stock market
crashed in 2000 web 3 is the biggest
technology infrastructure we've seen
since the internet so mobile since the
iPhone and
nfts are one of the most functional use
cases in crypto blockchain web 3 and I
think over the next decade they will
become omnipresent in our society and I
can't wait to watch it play out I'll end
with this because you talked about it
really quickly when we started you were
worried about saying certain stuff about
parenting because and you brought up
cancel
um you may rub some people the wrong way
you know that as you you're very vocal
about it what are your thoughts about
cancer culture and are you worried like
the you're nothing like him but like the
agitate of what's going on what's going
on in the world is that a good thing or
for for uh that people are being blocked
like what are your thoughts about what's
going on and you worry about it for
yourself I definitely don't worry about
it for myself I mean I've put out 50
pieces of content every day for a lesson
you know look I run people the wrong way
because I put pressure on people's
insecurities
I'm not out there tearing human beings
down
yep like
they're I'm very worried about cancer
culture because I think the left the
right the the the masculine feminine
like like I think everyone is spending
99 of their time tearing people down
I spend none of it
I wrote people the wrong way because
they think I'm too cocky
what what they don't realize it's their
own insecurity that's deploying that on
me they're not listening to what I'm
saying they're looking at the way I say
things because I'm a [ __ ] very hyper
East Coast well you're bringing out
something in them that they're that
they're happy with the reason um I mean
it's inconceivable for me to ever get
canceled I don't have a [ __ ] mean
bone in my body I'm competitive
um Scrappy I'm from the dirt I'm don't
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know like I got that
but you could you could strike up the
people who are like this guy swears too
much this shouldn't be on social media
let's take him down by the way if the
world gets to a place where they decide
that cursing is an incredibly bad thing
for society I'll be yes I would be
canceled and by the way that's what gets
people scared about platforms having the
say in the way they do I have a lot of
empathy for platforms I have a lot of
empathy for people I you know from my
standpoint I think cancel culture is a
real problem because everyone's doing it
I love when my Republican friends say I
hate your Democrat friends they cancel
everyone and the second a republican
within the Republican Party says
anything that doesn't fit for them they
cancel that person
and the [ __ ] left Democrats cancel
each other all that like they eat
themselves within themselves the world
is tearing people down 24 7 and it's
because most people don't know how to be
happy within themselves and don't
realize what a waste of energy it is to
judge and deploy that energy on other
people we should hold people accountable
but what's happened is it's gotten so
extreme that that's why you have a
counter to cancel because people are
trying to cancel people for the most
mundane somebody tried to cancel
somebody in one of my companies because
somebody's walking by and nicely said to
somebody hey guys and it was two women
and they like desperately wanted that
person fired
because they weren't guys but that's a
saying that's like a saying there was no
ill intent when we start taking intent
out of the equation and we're in gotcha
land
it's [ __ ] over and we're in gotcha
land right now in America and like
and that this is what happens when you
get so ridiculous that you're just
trying to get everyone it counters and
I'm very concerned because I think the
bad guys and gals are going to get away
with more bad
because now it's going to go through a
cycle where you can't cancel anything
for anything about anything yeah this is
just the way the [ __ ] world works I
don't worry about all that nonsense on
every side politics canceling feminism
masculine I don't think about any of
that [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] waking up every
day trying to do good and nice and just
[ __ ] going forward and whatever
communication infrastructure Community
reality that comes of it that's what
it's going to be and that's the way it's
going to be garyvee one of the greatest
stoic uh uh philosophers of our time
yeah I don't know you know it's funny
Once I learned that I have a lot of
those similarities like right holiday
others people hit me up they're like
you're stuck I'm like what's a stomach I
like looked and I'm like I
have a lot of that [ __ ] in me I you know
I don't really think about labels
that way because I know if I look deep
I'm sure there's things that I do that
aren't and that's awesome all of us none
of us are exactly a thing
um but I think we all need to deploy a
little bit more love and patience and
kindness and empathy and compassion and
sympathy and optimism and more self-love
the reason I'm nice to everybody is
because I love myself
I'd like people to have more of that or
I'm super lucky I can sit with you for
hours thank you Gary appreciate it
[Music]